rennes
dans la foule des inconditionnels ils
connaissent par coeur le répertoire de
kassav
les incontournables eva ces dames
bonjour avait endossé par ginger qui est
sale et v près d'une cinquantaine de man
se résume en 40 ans de chansons du
groupe morceaux qui font vibrer ces
milliers de fanatiques des fanatiques de
zouk qui devait composer avec la pluie
c'est donc munis de bottes de pulls de
parkas de ponchos qu'ils ont un zouk et
un concert avec le portable en main
forcément pour immortaliser 40 ans de
zouk et à la pluie durant sa commode
mais c'est excellent la puce est
important c'est pas grave on a vu plus
mr charles xii a rejeté en 30 ans
donnent la force d'un poste important
d'être là
[Musique]
9h14 anniversaire fantastique a pas il
viable de 40 ans disent qu'assad honda
manche je suis là où les 50 ans du t
bond à recommencer
ce concert événement est aussi un
soulagement pour les organisateurs qui
craignaient le mauvais temps donc on
galère avec le temps il n'a pas pris
pendant trois mois et j'ai juste le
week-end décide de faire les cons
servent plus c'était quand même
difficile à gérer mais je crois qu'on a
bien géré et le public vraiment avec la
pluie sont contents ils sont satisfaits
et on a fait ce site a pour ça et on
s'est rendu compte que même en temps de
pluie pour pouvoir créer des concerts
dont on est vachement content
[Musique]
ce concert de près de trois heures a
tenu toutes ses promesses
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'y être la date du 21 décembre à d'ores
et déjà été programmées
[Musique]
m